Should fight one another from the honour of leadership and not everybody knows who's in charge me. Yes
Subtitle- * I am HeRe * in description at last
Hey everybody is Charlie
this is gonna be my video for Thor for in guardians of the galaxy vol 3 or as
Guardians of the galaxy as we should call it
Unofficially Thor for we know a little bit about the plot and the characters of the movie in the story arcs
So we'll break it all down. If you're brand new to the channel. Be sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
We're also doing a new round of that IMAX. Take a giveaway
Like we have the new cut of Avengers and game hitting theaters and spider-man far from home
You can use the tickets for any movie that you want
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a Thor or spider-man comment on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of this. So I just broke this down top 7 style starting with rockets
supposedly the movie's gonna be dealing with his backstory James Gunn said that he
identifies with rocket most as a character in at one time when he was doing guardians to
He thought about doing a rocket Groot spin-off if he was ever gonna do a spin-off of any of the guardians characters
so it makes sense that they would deal with a lot of Rockets backstory in one of these films but
Supposedly the person who created him in the MCU will be the High Evolutionary
Who's a really weird and super deep cut Avengers villain from the comics the Guardians films pride themselves trading on really weird
Characters inside the MCU talking raccoon talking trees. So the High Evolutionary is not a big leap for them to make during the film
impressive
You're far more vibrant than my usual subjects I'll show you vibrant red
You will address me as the High Evolutionary
Nanos is rock and forget it do your worst. We ain't telling you squat
I have no Torah
Terrible fathers are also a running theme through all of the film's
Gamora's terrible dad in the first film of stano's Peter Quill's terrible dad ego
The Living Planet is the villain of the second film. It would make sense that another terrible
Dad would be one of the villains of the third film and it just so happens to be Rockets creator
If you're not really familiar with Rockets backstory in the Marvel Comics, he was actually from half world
But you also saw that during the line up during the first guardians film where you see he's from half world
But they don't really get into his backstory. He was a planet in the universe where a bunch of alien humanoids
They built a planet to be an insane asylum to watch and treat study a bunch of people they wound up leaving
but they left behind a race of robots to care for all the insane people on the planet a nearby
Explosion on a star created all this radiation the robots gained sentience
then they
themselves started experimenting in upgrading the animals that had been left behind his
Companions for the formerly insane humans that the planet had been originally created for. It's a really weird story
Obviously the High Evolutionary isn't part of the comic book version of that
So they're already changing some of Rockets comic book backstory, so don't worry too much about that right now
6 they're supposed to use the rocket backstory plot with a high evolutionary to introduce the lyla character from the comics
She's a talking otter in the way that rocket is a talking raccoon
She's supposed to be his soulmate and she's the heir to one of the largest companies on their homeworld
There was a story in the comics where they saved all the creations on their home planet then they flew away together on a spaceship
to live out their lives
so maybe rocket winds up getting a happy ending of sorts and winds up leaving the guardians at the end of the film the team's
Roster is gonna cycle
Anyway, if they continue as a group within the MCU regardless of whether or not they do guardians of the galaxy volume 4
But number 5 Drax is supposed to learn that his daughter is still alive
So presumably his arc in the film would be reuniting with her and going off to be a family again
so maybe he also leaves the Guardians team at the to the film because
Batista is getting up there in age and just like Hugh Jackman's said that it was just spine
Crushing to stay in shape to play The Wolverine character. It's the same deal for Dave Bautista playing Drax
It is really really hard for him to stay in that good of shape the physical toll that it takes on his body just performing
as the character if you've ever heard the nightmare than it is to get into Drax make up and then out of
Drax make up
You would also assume that in relative short order Drax would get his happy ending and sort of ride off into the sunset
So I don't expect him to stay on the Guardians team for forever. Zoe. Saldana is a makeup regime yesterday
Yours is pretty involved as well involves a sauna and shaving cream. Oh, yeah, it does
So that's so removed. So
Yeah, the great part about it is it goes on very fast about an hour and a half which is it was great for me
The first one was like four to six hours. The bad part is that it's it's very abrasive. It's like glue
So to get it off I have to sit in a sauna for about an hour
And so what we do is first they they erupted shaving cream all over me because it helps loosen up the makeup
It's really it's really it's really awful
Yes
We've gotten some strange looks but so I got my team their robes shaving cream all over me
Not getting a sauna for about 20 minutes by myself and then they about three guys join me and they start you know
Scrubbing this makeup
Remember the only reason he joined the Guardians in the first film was to kill thanos as revenge for
Thanos killing his family and as of the end of Avengers endgame
Both versions of Thanos are dead goal one achieved and two if his daughter were still alive
It would really complete his arc the story about him getting out of costume though is insane
So obviously it takes a long time to put the Drax makeup on before while looking for the younger Gamora from 2014
Remember Peter Quill's trying to track her down as the end of Avengers endgame
Nebula chills out even more and grows closer with Peter quill and the other Guardians
I don't think that there's anything romantically that's gonna be going on between the two of them
But remember what gomorrah's character arc was in the first and second guardians films
She starts out as this super hardcore person betrays Thanos then begrudging lee joins the guardians of the galaxy
Because they need each other's help to prevent the power stone from falling into Thanos his hands then by the second film
she's officially part of the
family in even acting like a very hardcore
mom and dad team with Peter quill all the while trying to get her sister nebula to chill out and join the cool kids for
super fun happy times
so after I murder my sister I
Will by worship with every conceivable instrument of death
I will hunt my father like a dog and I will tear him apart slowly
Piece by piece until he knows some semblance of the profound and unceasing pain. I know every single day
This time it would be
Nebula as the cool kid chasing after angry or Gamora to try and get her to chill out and join the family
I was a huge fan of the brief Iron Man and nebula scenes that we got during Avengers endgame
Karen Gillan is awesome as that character
So no idea if nebula and Gamora would leave the team at the end of the movie
maybe nebula stays on because I think the Karen Gillan really enjoys playing that character and I think that they've found
easier ways to get her into makeup
so it's not quite as brutal as they like Drax's makeup 3 Thor is supposed to be part of the movie as
guardians of the galaxy as implied by this ending scene from avengers endgame
but the way dave bautista
talked about Chris Hemsworth recently makes me wonder how much of the movie he's supposed to be part of because remember
James Gunn turned in his final script for the movie a couple years ago before that big debacle happened before we knew anything
About what was going on during Avengers endgame and where they were taking the Thor character
So Dave Bautista recently said I would love to have Chris Hemsworth as Thor in guardians of the galaxy vol 3
So I'm like wait a minute is Thor actually in the original version of the movie that James Gunn wrote or are they?
Changing things are they adding him? Later?
What's the deal odds are because people like Thor so much with guardians of the galaxy that maybe he's not a huge
part of the film
He's just a small part or the least
Referenced what's going on?
and then he goes off on his own by the end of the film if they use it as a sort of jumping-off point for
Whatever Thor 4 is going to be once they eventually make that movie - this is really cool
Supposedly the movie is finally gonna do a version of beta ray bill who we last saw as an easter egg during thor ragnarok
He was actually originally in a cut of that film but they took him out at the last minute
So he is a character in the MCU. He does exist. He's still alive
No idea what you're a beta ray bill
within the Thor
franchise is going to be or if beta ray bill would become a member of the guardians of the galaxy just because those films trade
On weird characters so much in beta ray bill is one of the weirdest characters that they would have ever done so far
I think if he continues as a character in the MCU and Thor for whatever other
Space-based films. It just depends on how much people like the character during guardians 3 and it's always possible
He could wind up being another deleted scene - so my beta ray bill
Expectations are actually pretty low, but he's a member of the korbinite race in the comics
He was originally introduced by Walt Simonson to be the first non
Asgardian Thor character to be deemed worthy enough to lift Thor's hammer. That was the whole idea
Somebody else who could finally live Thor's hammer around the world
After he does odin winds up forging him his own hammer that has similar powers to my own ear
And he just goes off on his adventures with Thor showing up every once in a while. The hammer itself is called Stormbreaker
So because Thor's new axe hammer in the MCU is called storm breaker
Maybe they'll have some fun with that idea
The thor ragnarok beta ray bill deleted scenes were just him fighting in the arena Planet Hulk style
Remember his face was on the side of the Grand Master's Tower meaning that he's one of the previous champions of the contest of Champions
Kevin Feige said that they did a lot of pre biz and he was in a version of the movie right up to the end
But they just felt like there was too much going on
so they just wound up cutting him out so that they could introduce him in a much bigger way in another Marvel movie rather than
Worry that they do him a disservice as a character by only just briefly showing him on screen in that's it
Not really explaining anything about the character. So even though he was in the movie for a long time
He wasn't ever going to be a really big part of it in number one
Of course, the movie is supposed to introduce Adam warlock
We all saw that during the guardians of the galaxy vol 2
post-credits scene first is a villain because he's being created by the sovereign who are villains - the guardians of the galaxy and then eventually
their ally because even if you're not an expert on Adam warlock comics
You probably know that he's mostly a good character in the comics
but you can see how introducing him as a villain and
Antagonist to the guardians at first as a way to reference his mages persona from the comics
There's rumors that it's supposed to be a Zac Efron
I don't totally believe that
But they probably have someone in mind because originally they were supposed to start shooting
Guardians 3 this past January before that big debacle happened
So they would have had to have already been talking to people about playing the character
But with the delay is not coming till
2022 now they could continue the search and as much as everyone is thinking about Keanu Reeves is Adam warlock
I don't think that that's what they're talking to Keanu Reeves about
They've been talking to candy Rees about playing a character in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Kevin Feige said that they've talked to Keanu Reeves every year about
every single Marvel movie they've ever made to try and find something for him to do because he's so fantastic and right now he's blowing
Up, of course, they want to get him in the MCU somewhere. Oh
yeah, ha ha
Yes, hold on one more
Yeah, I think he would make an amazing Adam warlock, but I just I don't think that they're going for him
It's just the idea that Adam warlock is a very spiritual character
But because of the spiritual characters that Keanu Reeves is known for playing you can understand how people will be theorycrafting
That maybe Adam warlock as the character that he's up for possible outcome for the guardians at the end of the movie though
Is that a new roster forms around either Thor for?
Permanent as guardians of the galaxy in Thor 4 or maybe Thor leaves at the end in Adam warlock
Winds up forming a new team of guardians presumably teenage Groot would finally grow to become full-sized adult Groot again
His race doesn't age like normal humanoids. He can grow to full size any time
He wants he just needs the sustenance to give himself energy for the change
So I would expect that the guardians as a team will continue on but the roster will be very different
They've been talking about doing a Nova film during Marvel phase four
It's always possible that they used the guardians movies to spin that character out unless it's gonna be some big prequel movie
It's a little too early to start introducing
Fantastic Four Silver Surfer Galactus
Characters but Silver Surfer would be an awesome Thor for crossover
So hopefully they'll find some way in the next couple of movies to introduce that character
There'll be a whole bunch more Marvel stuff happening next week
I'll do a post credit scene video for the new cut of Avengers endgame and obviously I'll be doing spider-man videos all week long
Leave your requests in the comments below
Congratulations Anthony Jordan. You're the giveaway winner from my last big Marvel video. Please email me on the about page of my channel
So I can get your contact details
click here for my New Avengers endgame
Post-credits scene video and click here for that funny new spider-man far from home scene and learn all about the spider-man venom
Crossover teaser from Kevin Feige. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight